excuse me this is my stuff say one more
time this is my stuff
what do you mean I buy this no wait
what's going on I I scan it you're
taking that from me what what
excuse me yo what's up wait what
happened I buy those stuff those
groceries those are mine
[Music]
Alan collie is accused of shooting a 21
year old man in the stomach yesterday
afternoon
they got him
they got who I think I ever shot the
part of the person yeah how do you feel
about that
it's a good thing
whoa they got the person who shot him
yeah
well I get okay yeah there's a see oh
hold on you see this face you see this
face that's a block twist yeah whatever
[__] play this [__] we'll find out
about to see U-turn today our Matthew
Torres spoke to the victim's family and
Matthew did they say what may have
caused all of this according to the
victim's family he was creating some
sort of a prank video for his YouTube
page and interacting with the suspect
when he
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
so he didn't shoot nobody for real no he
shot him for real the dude was trying to
prank up he said I don't [__] with it
he's like it's just a prank bro and he
shot him
[Applause]
gun these people down I'm not saying gun
these people down I'm not gonna say that
I am but I'm not mad at what happened
yo why is it like we got so many schools
we just need prank Shooters you get me
and interacting with the suspect when he
was shot court documents identified the
victim as Tanner cook tonight his father
telling me that he is expected to make a
full recovery
um I couldn't believe it but tonight
Jeremy cook says despite what happened
to his son he is slowly recovering in
the ICU it's his faith in God guiding
the family through this difficult
journey and I believe that God saved my
son's life and that he could have very
easily died and that's not the outcome
God taught your lesson you're gonna get
this bullet yeah you're going to live
it's not no yo yo listen [__] around and
find out leave people alone man you
ought to realize God's the ultimate
prankster you thought you was pranking
somebody imma say this your boy got shot
and you say thank God he can make a full
recovery so he can get back on YouTube
and do more nonsense no sir I don't want
to see that [__] again he didn't say
that but whatever
he didn't say that you're putting all
this words in his mouth he didn't say
that but carry on
and he don't say that his sons into some
dumb [__] that he oh he needs to own
that yeah but he didn't say that
his parents support his career if it's
March you'd have been like you know my
son deserved it you're doing it and I
would have deserved it I'm not I'm not
you want to pray people
parents should a raise this kid better
that's not what I'm saying what do you
say I'm saying what you said he said
this is not what he said you said none
of that it's what he didn't say it's by
Omission listen this thing is
this is
you raised a little sitter
oh and it was around him and and um they
were interviewing and we're talking
we're talking
yeah what did I [__] do yo I didn't
even watch the video I didn't watch the
video I had no idea what he's gonna say
but I know I know a bad parent when I
see him yay yay
yo yo let me cook cook I got my spatula
my oven
and my gas Chambers listen
I know a bad parent when I see one
cook them you see the way I'm trying to
cook you know what cook them I don't
know enough about this my bad but I
imagine if the main shot of this kid
must have been [__] around a lot but
we don't know so we gonna watch some of
these certified goon videos to find out
how annoying these pranksters can
potentially be according to the family
there is video of what happened but that
video is now evidence this father says
despite what Coley is accused of doing
he doesn't hold bitterness or anger
towards him we need healing we need to
come together no no yeah
I'm curious who these people are telling
workers they're being recorded prank
accusing people of stealing prank asking
strangers to whip my whistle prank
taking people's groceries prank yo
listen y'all want to keep [__] around
you're gonna find out steal the wrong
person's groceries get shot up Yay good
good and I know people like how could
you say that no people don't want to be
[__] with y'all want to go after
people you don't know what kind of
stress they got in their life they
sometimes one third away from breaking
and you just want to go [__] with them
and film it and put it online and make
them relive that embarrassment [__] you
yay
[__] you I never watched any of this I
didn't know but I could already tell if
somebody went as far as to shoot the
[__] these kids was antagonize
them like crazy then a lot of these
princes right now they go the extra mile
my dude my dude yeah do you see me
shutting the [__] up right now I'm just
saying okay cook them let's go watch
stealing me those groceries excuse me
this is nice stuff say one more time
this is my stuff
what do you mean I buy this no wait
what's going on I scan it you're taking
that from me what what excuse me yo
what's up wait what happened I buy those
stuff those groceries those are mine you
know man you see the Fire Bottle how
to get up
how's it going man disappear in front of
me okay bro homie tried to fight me over
his paper towels that's actually comedy
but uh me personally like if someone's
trying to take my groceries I'm probably
giving the same reaction I feel like
everybody is not gonna let anyone take
their groceries but uh bro that was that
was hilarious nah [__] nah [__] get
shot get shot get shot
[__] need to learn nah bro get shot I
know you said you don't wish it on I
wish it on no no I wish it on do you see
me right now shutting the [__] up sorry
I ain't fat [__] I just I ain't said
[__] he lives
I said I said cook them and you're
cooking me I'm just saying it annoys me
because we've been saying this dumb [__]
gonna happen we've been saying that
we've been saying that and then it's
becoming more popular and listen I love
you Dion That's the homie but like I
think because of how he does his stuff
so many people trying to emulate some
people do it poorly but that's been
happening some people do it poorly but
it's been
yeah the bottom where it started from
was Ashton Kutcher punked
that was because it was on MTV where MTV
back then was the internet of the TV
right and that's where it started and
when internet came up it was popping
everybody started doing that a lot of
these things were fake and arranged and
stuff like that you know I mean and
arranging to certain stuff where when
you're punking someone
and you have acolytes that are friends
of the person and no that's not the same
thing that we're doing here you're
punking random people and doing some
pretty egregious stuff because you want
reactions that's what you're doing and
when you want reactions what is gonna
happen is a reaction and you're really
excuse it as it's a prank we I cannot
stress this [__] enough people got hard
lives and stuff like that and you're
messing with them and ain't got time for
that true if they telling you know
whatever whatnot and you keep on going
to have that extra reaction you're gonna
get that and you're if you're egregious
enough to bother someone that you pull
out the gun and free money Island
free my dude Allen
you pull out that he pulls out that I we
knew that [__] was about to happen leave
people leave the people them alone yeah
leave them alone like I said the dude
lived some people think that's good I
don't know I just hope you learned your
lesson that's it I really just hope you
love your lesson that's it [__] around
and find out cause the next time you do
that you're not gonna have the same
courtesy yeah I might not wish death on
people but I do hope they get decked in
the face they give you that that
absolutely I want to go up to people and
test them and say some random
disrespectful stuff or [__] with their
belongings and take their [__] from them
yeah you deserve to get punched in the
face
but if you're looking for a reaction
you're gonna get that yeah you're
getting punched in the face is part of
the option yeah you young you young
[__] is just I don't know who raised
some of y'all maybe it was just the
internet but you guys are raised like
Savages again I say this all the time oh
old head old head whatever I don't give
a [__] at least we learn respect
you you wouldn't even touch our Man's
Shoes
without expecting a fight you guys are
taking people's food and groceries
bumping someone accusing people of
stealing y'all deserve everything that
comes to you whether it's jail getting
shot I don't give a [__] and if you do
end up dying I won't feel bad I don't
wish it on you but I won't feel bad I'll
post the video and I'll repost it a
couple times just so it serves as a
reminder to others not to do this dumb
[__] hell yeah [__] them anything
positive to say um
outside troll you [__] psych I got the
one yeah I know what he troubles you
trying to throw me in the [__] you know
what I got hit I thought I was gonna get
you with this video I got me
I got me you pranked yourself
you don't reverse that [__] I gotta hit
that [__] you with that Yu-Gi-Oh you
activated my trap card and then you get
trapped
that's so stupid I felt like I just dug
a hole and then jump right yeah oh [__]
my legs
what am I getting mad about that that's
all you that's all you I just I just
couldn't imagine that's all it is I
couldn't imagine right I don't know
growing up I just went through so much
trouble not to do that to not cross the
line you just know how to act around
people because you don't want to be out
here fighting all the time growing up I
got into some trouble not messing with
people exactly how you want to go out
there and and purposely mess with people
you want to you want to purposely put
yourself up yo life is real some people
are living life on easy mode right now
yeah and I'm not talking about just you
ladies I'm talking about some of you
kids you know I mean you're living life
on easy mode we didn't do [__] and we
had [__] going on just breathing through
a school you would get you would get
[__] happening to you walking down the
street bumping the wrong person you
could get dripped right through you
understand what I'm saying and now you
gonna purposely yo that [__] [__] with
people people say we were overreacted
when we saw that Kai snack video but I'm
like no like a lot of that [__]
was upset and annoyed one of them even
threatened to fight him because he's
like why are you [__] with me at my
job I don't find this [__] funny I
understand the sentiment
yeah some people are gonna love it enjoy
it great a lot of people not and you
don't know who those people are it's
just like this some women might like it
if you grab that ass but you shouldn't
go around grabbing everybody else
because don't get surprised if they
smack you in the [__] face right and
then or if the boyfriend comes up and
beats your ass afterwards oh it's a
prank it some people like it I don't
care
did you ask before no of course not
because it's a prank
so it is listen Frankie is one of the
only things I think people do that [__]
with but if you've gotten physical
people's faces or touched them or say
some foul [__] to them like hypothetical
if you go up to a bunch of random women
you say hey you [__] [__] whatever
all right nobody would say that shit's
kosher you can't just go up to random
people and yell that [__] to them right
nobody would say she's kosher but if you
say it's a prank all of a sudden that
[__] makes it cool no some of y'all
punch in the [__] face absolutely and
I I endorse it I can't wait to title
this video I'll just put it prankster
gets shot amazing so righteous
I was right about the dead though [__]
bro I told you yeah I know I just like
being reminded I told you I told you
like your wife she wanted me riding
Supreme I told you you're right I'm
right I told you cook them and you
started cooking me instead it's like
wrong stove [__] wrong stove wrong you
turn off my stove initially no I didn't
yeah you did you did I did what he said
I gave him the benefits
I wait I'll wait till the [__]
bring the vegetables till I cook you was
just cooking thin hair nah you know why
because even though the vegetables were
dethawed I'd already done the math in my
head shut that [__] no no no no no no I
took the vegetables out the freezer you
didn't do [__] I did you didn't I didn't
put back I said let that [__] thought
some people got a cookbook in a recipe
they know their timers I just go with
the flow
I'm an intuitive cooker I know the
ingredients coming
I got Chef Boyardee delivering to the
door you feel me so I don't even need to
know it's here yet I'm like cooking turn
on the pan [__] he got five minutes
away I could feel it in my chest you
don't understand that sentiment you
don't hit it that's why you turned off
the heat
and so I got mad I'm not gonna lie I'm
like hey [__] who [__] on my kitchen
that was you but you know what [__]
we're in the same thing yeah I got time
this is the same kitchen that we're in
we're talking it's my kitchen too it's
my kitchen too yeah but there's two
stones right there's there's the other
tops over there on the right side and
the other ones on the left side you got
yours you turned off mine though bruh
this turned off mine I was in the middle
of my [__] you turned off mine knowledge
is going too far Hey Hey listen we cook
it and there's a bunch of people at home
right now I let you cook
Hey listen you ever you cook and then
somebody come and start [__] with
your pots and pants no cause I got mine
yeah yeah yeah yeah
I know but you don't like it and she
don't lie no I don't care cause I bought
my own house
stop being with a roomy you can afford
it what you mean people are not gonna
hear why your wife you know never when I
cook I cook yeah see she because you
know I just wish you could do the same
for me no this is what I stole that's
awesome yeah what roomies in this [__]
it's not a stove between you I can turn
that [__] off if I want to between you
and your wife it's not y'all stoves it's
no it's my stuff
it has been
no stop yeah no cause I bought the beach
so you got a wife but it's your kitchen
yeah yeah
Hey listen this is information this is
cool this is why she has her own kitchen
there's two kitchens no there's Maltese
there's no two kitchens but she bought a
condo that she's wearing out she's
bringing her kitchen to someone else
yeah that's my kitchen
I said yeah she got a kitchen and then
you just saw a picture of one of them
Easy Bake Ovens hey hey making me
cookies but anyways that's it let us
know what you guys